there's new research from the Department
of Homeland Security revealing that heat
and humidity and the sunlight might have
a powerful impact on kilink ovid 19-hour
most striking observation to date is the
powerful effect that solar light appears
to have on killing the virus both
surfaces and in the air
the virus is dying at a much more rapid
pace just from exposure to higher
temperatures and just from exposure to
humidity so the virus dies the quickest
in the presence of direct sunlight under
these conditions
so what does this mean as we approach
the warmer weather this summer here to
discuss is Fox News medical contributor
dr. mark Siegel hey dr. Siegel morning
Ainsley good to see you good morning
good to see you too so what do you
gather now that you've heard this
information this is good news from
Department of Homeland Security this is
what we look for as the weather warms is
humidity impacting a virus is heat and
his solar light the this chart they
showed yesterday shows that the virus is
killed within two seconds on surfaces
and one and a half seconds when in the
air this is consistent Aynsley with the
SARS virus in 2003 the exact same thing
and that virus if you recall ended up
dying out now that's no guarantee here
that this will be a seasonal virus but
we've been talking about this for a long
time here so as dr. Fauci so is dr.
Redfield of CDC they told me this just
last week that there's evidence that
this may very well be a seasonal virus
what does that mean it means that you
may still see some cases stretching
forward into June because it's a
pandemic meaning that there's not a lot
of immunity to slow it down but the
seasons may slow it down and it doesn't
spread nearly as effectively when it
gets warmer it looks like yeah dr.
Siegel the vice president said yesterday
he thinks this will largely be behind us
in a month labor I mean Memorial Day
weekend so is this just a time for us to
breathe and then it comes back in the
winter you what are you hearing about
the vaccines what we have won by the
time the flu comes back around and kovat
well first of all Aynsley to your first
question we're looking at Australia now
the southern hemisphere Argentina we're
looking down under to see what's
happening now
we're not seeing a surge of cases down
there remember their fall is starting
now so you want to know what happens in
our fall that's what we do with the flu
season every year we look to the fall of
the southern hemisphere now to see
what's happening there's not a surge of
cases which maybe we have to watch this
over the next month maybe shows we won't
have a big second way we certainly hope
so
in the meantime world we're looking at
perfecting these treatments we're
looking at different antiviral
treatments different targeted therapies
we're looking at REM Desa vir what
clinical trials are about to come out
the vaccine because we have to go very
carefully with this it's still probably
about a year away hopefully that can be
hastened but we can't breathe totally
until we have a vaccine but if we have
all the antibody testing we need to know
who is exposed and who's immune that
will help us loosen restrictions as well
and that's something that's starting to
be ramped up now so I really want to see
more and more testing antibody testing
to see who's immune as we wait for the
treatments to emerge I know I think we
all do thank you so much dr. Siegel have
a great weekend we'll see you on Monday